continuamos con información en france 24
y hablamos ahora de economía y estamos
para eso con daniel hablando nuestra
periodista que nos va a contar lo más
importante hoy daniela bienvenida
empezamos hablando de la ocde que
actualizó su proyección de contracción
de la economía mundial así de liliana
muy buenas noches pues a lo largo de los
últimos meses el que también es conocido
como el club de países ricos ha previsto
que el producto interno bruto mundial va
a caer un 6% sin embargo ya está
considerando un escenario un poco más
pesimista
esto es solo en el caso de que haya una
ola de la pandemia
cilia
si hay una segunda bola podríamos
esperar una disminución global del
producto interno bruto del 75 por ciento
en 2020 el mundo del set de mí es
justamente hoy este organismo publicó un
informe sobre el panorama educativo de
2020 y dijo a los gobiernos que ahora en
la pandemia deben priorizar la inversión
en educación para que la crisis no
acentúe las desigualdades y puso como
ejemplo que según esta investigación 8
de cada 10 jóvenes que tienen estudios
superiores consiguen trabajo pero esa
cifra baja a sólo 6 de cada 10 jóvenes
cuando nos siguen estudiando después del
bachillerato
daniela estados unidos bloqueó las
importaciones de dos productos clave de
china
bueno son el tomate y el algodón
provenientes de la región de xinjiang en
el oeste de china de donde sale una
quinta parte de todo el algodón que se
consume en el mundo la razón que plantea
eeuu es que su producción se basa en
trabajos forzados
como se sabe de washington está
aumentando cada vez más su presión sobre
beijing por el trato que les da a los
musulmanes uigures
en esta zona del país de hecho naciones
unidas ha dicho que tiene pruebas de que
al menos un millón de miembros de esta
comunidad ha sido sometidos a malos
tratos y trabajos forzados en
campamentos pero china alega que son
centros de formación profesional lo
cierto es que esta medida sin
precedentes probablemente va a agudizar
la guerra comercial entre las dos
economías más grandes del mundo liliana
bueno a daniela pues de principal asesor
legal de boris johnson renunció ante la
atención por el break city si estamos
hablando de jonathan jones cuya dimisión
se debe a las discrepancias en el
gobierno por su intención de alterar el
acuerdo de salida del reino unido- de la
unión europea justo hoy inició la octava
ronda de negociaciones en medio de las
amenazas del reino unido- de irse
abruptamente del bloque comunitario
mientras tanto el parlamento europeo le
pide más compromiso al primer ministro
boris johnson quien recibió críticas hoy
nada más y nada menos que de theresa may
quien es su antecesora
y este parlamento voto este pacto de
retirada bajo la legislación del reino
unido- el gobierno ahora está cambiando
su operación dado esto como puede el
gobierno tranquilizar a sus futuros
socios internacionales para que confíen
en que reino unido cumplirá las
obligaciones legales de los acuerdos que
firman
está estancada la cosa por el lado del
break sí daniela y la curiosidad
económica del día cuál es cuéntenos
bueno pues estos datos pueden
interesarles a quien piense viajar a
europa o incluso vivir en ese continente
pues un estudio realizado en 37 países
por eurostat que es la oficina de
estadísticas mostró cuáles tienen la
comida y las bebidas alcohólicas a mayor
y a menor precio liliana los resultados
son los siguientes mire ciudad es el
país que vende la comida más cara y en
macedonia del norte está la más barata
por su parte en bebidas alcohólicas
usted encontrará las más costosas en
islandia y las más económicas en bosnia
y herzegovina aunque si el que se va a
ir para europa es un fumador empedernido
pues es mejor que no piense ir a noruega
porque allá lo venden al precio más caro
entre estos 37 países de los que le
abrió interesante daniela cuéntanos
cuáles son los indicadores de la jornada
bueno son tercera jornada consecutiva de
números rojos en wall street arrastrada
por en las tecnológicas nasdaq perdió
más del 4 por ciento en medio del
desplome de empresas como tesla
esto hizo que las bolsas europeas
también tuvieran fuertes descensos en la
jornada de hoy aunque también están
pendientes del presi
casi todas bajaron más del 1 por ciento
y en américa latina en las principales
bolsas bursátiles no se escaparon del
contagio de la bolsa de nueva york y
también tuvieron pérdidas y la cifra al
día son los 800 millones de dólares que
se comprometió a invertir uber para que
su flota sea 100% eléctrica para 2040 en
europa eeuu y canadá gracias por la
información de colombia daniela y
ustedes gracias por estar con nosotros
continúen con más entradas 24 punto com
i